[music playing]
[ding]
INTERVIEWER: (VOICEOVER) One of
the big players in that world,
someone I'm told moves
more than a million
worth of product daily,
has agreed to meet me--
well, kind of.
INTERVIEWER: OK, we ready?
GEORGE: Yep.
So I'm currently in an empty
room and in front of a table
with nine pounds of all sorts
of different kinds of weed.
George, I'm just
explaining what's
happening to the cameras.
Because it feels really weird
that it's just me here so
I'm just explaining.
GEORGE: Yep.
INTERVIEWER: (VOICEOVER)
George didn't
want his actual voice recorded.
George is actually
out of view.
He didn't feel comfortable
being on camera,
but he can hear me
because of my mic.
INTERVIEWER: (VOICEOVER) So
we're using a voice changer
that alters it while he speaks.
If I were a buyer,
I would come in here.
You'd have all
these bags out here
with the different samples.
They'd look at it, smell it,
possibly try it, smoke it.
GEORGE: Some will smoke
it, but it's really just,
you know, based off
the smell, mainly
the smell, then the look.
And then they place orders.
Is that it?
GEORGE: Yep.
INTERVIEWER:
(VOICEOVER) On the table
is a variety of high end
exotic indoor and outdoor weed.
Each pound bag costs
between $2,000 and $4,000.
What's the largest order
you've ever received?
GEORGE: I mean, they'll go
up to hundreds of pounds.
INTERVIEWER: (VOICEOVER)
Just one order that size is
worth around a million dollars.
INTERVIEWER: How
much money is there
to be made in illegal weed?
GEORGE: Oh, endless,
endless amounts.
I shouldn't really be
talking about this to someone
for camera.
INTERVIEWER: (VOICEOVER)
I decide not to push it.
So George, you operate
just a black market business?
Or do you operate
also a legal business?
GEORGE: Licensed as well.
Licensed as well.
If you were to give me a general
sense of how much money you
make with your legal versus
your illegal business,
what would you say?
GEORGE: Well, technically,
I haven't made profit
off my legal business yet.
Wow.
GEORGE: They try to
kill you with fees,
taxes, regulations, hoops to
jump through, inspections.
They go 10 times overboard
than any other business.
I wish for them to do
the same regulation
to an alcohol company.
So why operate a legal
business if you're not
even making money out of that?
GEORGE: For the love of it.
Why do artists like to paint?
Or why does a
singer like to sing?
I roll with the punches now
and just hanging in there
so that big business
doesn't just take
all the original people out.
You know, you don't
feel comfortable with even
being in the same room.
Why do you think there's
so much fear and mistrust?
GEORGE: It's kind of
ingrained in our culture.
You can't really trust people.
And that just comes
with money and greed.
And when people are
greedy, bad things happen.
Do you carry a gun?
GEORGE: I have guns.
Robberies happen left and right.
In a situation if
you get robbed,
you really have no
choice but to use it.